aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui reste 36 ans
après la même chose les restos sont
toujours là malheureusement on est
toujours là 21 décembre 1985 lancement
des restos du coeur
c'est quoi ta télé 5000 bénévoles
s'activent dans 18 villes pour
distribuer des repas 36 ans plus tard
patrice duret président des restos
revient sur cette première édition
lancée par coluche ça devait ne pas
durer et même là la chaîne la première
saison il a même versé un excédent à la
vespière ce qu'il a dit mais nous nous
reste un petit peu on vous donnait et
vous allez pouvoir continuer de la
débrouille en 1985 c'était ça les restos
du coeur ici à gennevilliers les
bénévoles s'organisent 600 repas
gratuits vont être distribués à
gennevilliers au nom de paris sous un
chapiteau cela grâce à vingt bénévoles
membres d'une association des deux
toxicomanes ils ont en un temps record
trouver un chapiteau une municipalité
accueillante et démarcher les
entreprises voisines ci a changé aussi
c'est bien évidemment les conditions
matérielles on peut plus aujourd'hui
accueillir dans des chapiteaux tels que
cet effet là on a besoin de locaux qui
permet d'accueillir dignement on ne peut
pas accueillir dans le centre des
personnes moins bien que là où elles
vivent à l'époque la france connaît un
chômage de masse un nouveau profil se
pressent aux portes des restos
maintenant ça va cette catégorie de gens
qui sont des chômeurs qui ont une
famille
tu vois c'est pas des clochards qui
vivent dehors on s'est bien passé ça
fait quelque chose au coeur parce qu'on
voit peu on voit quand même que les gens
ne sont pas délaissés que les pauvres
faut il dit 36 ans plus tard les profils
restent les mêmes qu'on a vu apparaître
lors de la crise sanitaire notamment sur
le premier confinement s'est beaucoup de
travailleurs précaires des travailleurs
libéraux des auto entrepreneurs de plus
en plus de familles monoparentales dont
la chef de famille et hétu est une femme
est une dame autre info d'importance le
nombre de repas distribués pendant cette
première édition coliche peut continuer
aidé par 5000 bénévoles il a gagné son
pari 8 millions de repas ont été
distribués cet hiver 8,5 millions
précisément 1985 un chiffre multiplié
par 16 aujourd'hui sur la dernière
campagne la 36e campagne ses 142
millions qui ont été distribués c'est à
dire que c'est plus que l'année
précédente on a une augmentation
constante le nombre de repas est un peu
notre unité de mesure mais c'est
extrêmement significatif aujourd'hui les
restos du coeur reste indispensable
1,2 million de personnes en ont
bénéficié en france lors de la dernière
campagne en 2021 ces restos c'est à dire
qu'on est née d'un clone on le fait en
fait sérieusement avec une rigueur de
gestion qui est assez importante mais
c'est 70 mille bénévoles à qui doit le
faire avec le sourire il faut absolument
que les gens qui viennent le chez-nous
repartent avec un petit sourire la
banane quoi voilà
[Musique]